to be fair I got to point out the
reviews when the album came out
universally almost without exception
were glowing I mean people really the
the critics whatever that means to you
guys at the time thought it was fabulous
work bad review
sting I wouldn't
know never a bump in the road I hear an
echo um uh yes they do those fabled
electrical audio Acoustics is what
you're hearing
yeah no but it's uh it
was it was appreciated uh when it came
out and of course one of the
difficulties is that once Kurt
died everybody had to go back and parse
through in utero and read lyrics like
their tea leaves leading you somewhere
and that feels like a recipe for
incredible bull and
misunderstanding you can do it with
sound Garten lyrics
too but you
know yeah it's strange when we were
making the record we did all of the
instrumental tracks first I don't know
if Kurt sang any of the songs live it
was all just the three of us doing the
instrumental tracks first live in the
room without really having ever
heard uh what Kurt was going to sing or
even how he was going to sing it like
his his Melodies and patterns that most
of these things I just listen to them as
instrumental so it was always exciting
like a mystery knowing like oh he's in
there singing this track today and
wondering what it was going to sound
like when he was finished and one of you
know one of
Kurt's U amazing abilities was not just
that he was a great Lyricist but he had
a really specific
um kind of signature melodic turn of
phrase so he could he he always braided
really two simple lines together I think
in a way that um was almost
unpredictable and he would go from like
maybe a gentle voice to a scream or
maybe a minor key to a major but he
would do it in this way that was like
really beautifully patterned which I
always thought was really cool and
really simple ultimately most everything
that he did I thought was simple but
really smart you know anyway so you
would hear these things as they came
back and you would hear um for the first
time his melodic idea but also the the
lyric and
um every time you would hear every time
I would hear it for the first time I'd
think that's just that's just odd that's
unusual ual it's a it's a
weird uh what a strange thing to say
what does that mean but as the drummer
of course I'm like did I slow down
in the chorus no my kick drums too
you know it's I still to this day if I
listen to that record I'll find things
or I'll feel things that I didn't
necessarily feel 25 years ago um not
just in light of everything that had
happened but um but of course that you
know everything that did happen can
you know kind of screw the lens a little
bit or distort maybe what it felt like
before and what it feels like now
um yeah I mean
I I think it's a slippery slope it's
easy to to look back at that stuff and
yep there's there's a thing that people
don't give Kurt credit for enough which
is
that like a lot of people think of his
lyrical sensibility as just being a
journal of his feelings right he was an
artist and he was incorporating stuff
from you know other things other
influences bands and records that he
admired stuff that he'd read like
literature there's a line in one of the
songs I think it's um most babies smell
like butter is that you know what I'm
talking about yeah and I was like what a
weird observation did you like smell a
baby and like he just had a kid right
and and and I found out that that was a
a near direct quote from a book that
he'd read about a guy who had this sort
of sensory experience of the world that
was abnormal andless Apprentice yeah
sess Apprentice a track on the on in
utero yeah and uh you know and then like
he's he's from Seattle and Francis
Farmer is a tragic figure a local person
to the to Seattle area like a lot of
lore involved and there like there had
been recently come to light a lot of the
sort of manipulative stuff that had been
done to her uh during her career to try
to manage her career like you can see
that there are parallels there where
there you know like he may have been
feeling pressures from outside people
trying to manage his artistic expression
for their benefit and seeing a parallel
between his life and Francis Farmer's
Life and then using her as figure like H
and it's such a great title for a song
yeah and that image of leaving a blanket
of Ash burn all the and leave a
blanket of Ash on the ground but uh and
also it felt like a little bit of a
reaction to read somewhere once I think
that there was so many just one name
songs uh and that Kurt was really
interested in like going the other way
so it's Francis Farmer will have her
revenge
the ghost of Francis well we'll have her
revenge on Seattle just as this or at
radi friendly you know shipping unit
what that these were attempts to say I'm
reacting to this cute moment we're in
where everything is just one word and he
was aware of that as a Trope and he was
play and he played with it he had there
was the one song he wanted to call
gallons of rubbing alcohol roll through
the strip that we had that gam yeah we
did that
and is there much he was he also wanted
to be
he he didn't want to be like like be
dated or be put in like some kind of box
or something so he also was just
cryptic and and that allowed people to
just invite people in to make their own
interpretation of it then if you look at
his other forms of expression like Steve
said like Kurt was an artist and he was
he was a great painter he was a sculptor
he would do um comic books and he's more
than happy to walk you through every
panel of like a comic he did like and um
and they were always just tragic figures
to people and they were or just weird
like writhing Spirit Apparition kind of
everything was just kind of strange and
dark and weird but then still but very
well done you know be beautiful very you
know done done very well so that was
when he was expressing himself
musically is that you know in in uos
that's all over in utero you know I can
go anywhere in the
world walk anywhere in the
world anywhere and see someone walking
down the street in a Nirvana T-shirt and
I was I mean we're here in Chicago we
were walking last night to go get a bite
to eat saw someone in a Nirvana T-shirt
but I mean I could be
in you know I could be on Guam and just
see someone randomly walk by in a
Nirvana T-shirt and what what always
strikes me about these moments is that
there's this massive projection that
happens which is um Nirvana Legend Kurt
it all gets prismed out it gets so huge
and then I talk to you guys and he's
your
friend that you knew intimately you guys
were very
close
and it's all become so much bigger there
are people out there that have opinions
strong opinions about who he was and
what he meant and what you guys
meant and it must just seem surreal to
you at times like no no no that was our
that was our friend there was three of
us we were in this we were in a van
together and it has now
become
um this IMAX projection on the world
when my kids sometime will ask me let's
say
uh my daughter Harper and I were driving
in the car not not long ago 6 months ago
and a Nirvana song came on and we don't
listen to Nirvana at home
um this Nirvana song comes on she's
singing along to the words and I'm
thinking wow that's weird I've never
heard her listen to a Nirvana song how
does she know a Nirvana song and she
says
um she said Dad how old were you when
you made this
song so God I think I was like
22 maybe she goes oh
uh how old was Kurt I said I think his
he was maybe like 23 24 she goes what
was he
like and i' say well he was he was
really nice kind of
shy um sometimes quiet but he was
cool get super pissed off yeah but she
says well um he was shy was he shy
around people that he knew or people
that he didn't know and I said well the
kind of a little bit of of both and she
said God that's so strange that someone
who feels shy like that that could write
these songs and sing them for everyone
to hear and then stand on stage in front
of a 100,000 people and play them I
thought that was so cool because I think
she wasn't looking so much at that other
thing y she was looking at the person
right and you know after Nirvana was
over that that curtain got sort of like
sort of pulled away so it changed the
way I thought about every other
mythological rock star that I'd ever
followed in my entire life and it really
made me realize oh
they were an actual human being we
talked like they're playing cards or
something like that but they're just
people